hey everybody my name is mayuko and
welcome back to my channel where we talk
about tech
career and life so we've been
quarantining for months at this point
and i feel like i've got kind of a
routine down for
my work day so today in this video i'm
going to show you my work from home
routine in
quarantine so let's get started so on
work days i usually wake up anywhere
between 7 45
and 8 15. so as part of waking up i
brush my teeth i wash my face
and i get dressed for the day and on
some days of the week
i'll work out before my work day i'm
usually more of like a evening workout
person but
i've been working out in the mornings
recently and it's been really helping to
ground me
and improve my mental health during this
weird time
and at 9 00 a.m i have my daily stand-up
so i work for myself now but one thing
that i really miss
about working at a company or at an
office is just kind of the regular
routine of seeing co-workers every day
and so a couple of friends and i started
this daily stand-up group for ourselves
we're all creative professionals who've
had careers in the tech industry
so we meet monday through friday at 9 00
am for about 15 minutes to do
a stand-up in each stand-up we talk
about what we did yesterday and what
we're doing today
and it's been a really good structure
for accountability and an incredible
support group
so after stand-up is over i do kind of
the rest of my morning routine
between showering after my workout
eating breakfast
and taking my dog for a walk so all in
all it takes me about two hours to get
ready for the day
which does feel a little bit long
especially given that i don't need a
commute anywhere
but those two hours are really precious
in that it helps me to context switch
from being
at home to kind of like a work mode
because especially if we're not changing
our surroundings then it's the mindset
and mentality that needs to change
and so during that two hours i slowly
but surely kind of get myself
into that mode so then at around 10 a.m
i sit down and start working until lunch
in the mornings i'm most often checking
on emails and other correspondences
as well as just planning my day and the
rest of the week to make sure that i'm
on track to do what i set out to do
in the morning my brain is the most
fresh so after catching up on emails and
such
i kind of let it do what it needs to do
on this day i was researching a project
management tool to help me plan for
upcoming projects
and i also just decided to rearrange my
room i just wanted to do this that day
because i've been meaning to move this
organizer into the closet and felt like
it was a good time as i need to do so
and especially during quarantine because
your scenery doesn't change that often
i find that refreshing my space really
also refreshes my mind and soul
and now i'm just walking downstairs to
eat lunch
so at noon time i always eat lunch even
though technically i could eat lunch at
any time that i want
eating lunch at the same time every day
gives me some sort of structure and
routine to my days
i'm usually talking to scott during
lunch and just really appreciating the
food and unplugging from work during
this time
and after lunch i might clean a little
bit since we're all working from home
it's really hard to have that separation
between work and home
and so having these hours set where this
is work time and this is home time
has really helped me to maintain that
balance so then around one o'clock every
day
my afternoon work time commences usually
this means that i turn on my twitch
stream where i host co-working
co-studying co-coding streams it's been
really good to have this dream because
there's a lot of people in the same boat
who
join in on the stream they're all also
working from home and i feel like we've
all become kind of like
co-workers together we use the pomodoro
method to differentiate between work
time and social time
and we play kind of chill lo-fi hip-hop
music throughout
and so while i have the stream on i will
literally do work
in the afternoon i'm likely continuing
work that i started in the morning or
just starting something completely
different that's on my to-do list
usually my really time intensive work
happens in the afternoon so that might
be video editing or
coding but because the afternoon work
stretches so long i make sure to take
breaks in between
the pomodoro timer we use on the stream
certainly helps me to focus
but i also let my brain just kind of
turn off sometimes or peruse the
internet or learn something new
and that's why i wanted to thank the
sponsor of today's video brilliant
giving myself time and space to learn
new things throughout the day has really
helped me to avoid burnout
and stay inspired and creative brilliant
is a website that has a bunch of courses
in the sciences some of the courses dive
into really complex topics
and so it really helps me to really
think about new problems in new ways
they're all interactive and they break
down complex topics with great visuals
teaching you how to think and learn so
take a course on brilliant and start
your journey today
by going to brilliant.org slash hello
myuco and sign up for free and the first
200 people to go to that link will get
20
off the annual premium subscription
anyway
during the long stretch of the afternoon
where i'm working one of the things that
i do to kind of freshen things up is to
change location
on this day i had a meeting at the very
end of the day so
i went downstairs to just change my
environment
i made myself a very nice barley tea and
had a great meeting
[Music]
and then my work day concludes at around
5 30. so i hope you like this video
where i show you my work from home
routine in quarantine
make sure to hit that subscribe button
if you'd like to see more videos and
i'll see you next time
stay safe out there